[Music]
I have a friend of mine who's a very
famous writer and I'll leave him
nameless for the moment but he writes
very dark novels and when I first met
him I was surprised he was so cheerful
and I said how can he be so cheerful he
looked at me and he said I'm a pessimist
but that's no reason to be gloomy and
that's become a mantra in some sense and
it seems particularly appropriate when
you think about the universe because the
universe first of all does isn't here to
make us happy it isn't here to please us
and it doesn't give a damn what happens
to us and the far future the universe is
likely to be miserable as I talked about
in my last book and I point out my new
book could even be more miserable so in
a purposeless universe that may have a
miserable future you may wonder well how
can I go about each day and the answer
is we make our own purpose we make our
own joy we are here by a cosmic accident
as I've tried to show that it's a
remarkable accident that's allowed you
and I to be here to talk us to think and
appreciate the beauty and splendour of
the universe
so the fact that that the universe
itself may have no purpose doesn't
affect our purpose in fact it's the
incredible height of solids is 'm to
assume that without us the universe
doesn't matter and that if the universe
is purpose purposeless
we don't matter we make our own purpose
and it seems to me life is more precious
because it's temporary and accidental
and we should take advantage of that and
we have evolved brains and that allows
us to ask questions not just about how
the universe works but how we should
behave now it's a long philosophical
debate about whether you can get aught
from is and maybe you can never get off
from is and maybe reason it's a slave of
passion but one thing seems clear to me
that without knowing what is you can
never get too OTT or if you do the art
that you get to is silly if you don't
know the consequences of your actions
which is really what science tells us
then you can't assess how to behave and
so understanding empirical phenomena is
a central plays a central role in
leading a better life it seems to me and
it should play a central role in public
policy so that we as a society can make
sound decisions about how to
in the common good
[Music]